[Music]
what's going on guys so the Academy
Award nominations have been announced
and I think you and I can both agree to
kind of mess it up a little bit so we
here at screen junkies decided to get
together all of us in a room that was a
little too warm and started to get a
little gamey and we were in there for a
couple hours but we figured out what the
nomination should be if we were the
Academy here we go the first category
Best Supporting Actor looking at the
choices it seems like there's two that
had a lot of consensus behind them they
would seem to have a majority unless
anyone has a major objection no all
right so there's two I think Helen I
want to want to take on merge a little
bit with one of the nominees oh yeah one
up there yeah math chicken beds Esther
scrub after chicken is your nominee I
would contend that math chicken should
possibly be a Best Actress nominee
because I think it was a hen not a
rooster Rob Delaney does anyone want to
back up any support for Rob Delaney
intentful - he stole every scene he was
in for me when we vote for best mustache
later okay
Sam Rockwell's okay so ice I posited
that one Sam Rockwell's excellent he was
the one for me that felt like a sketch
care yeah to me I thought that Steve
Carell was gonna strums phones we'll
take him up or do we replace him with
Steve Carell well considering that we
have many more slots than we need I
think I think Brad take a mock well yeah
we should congratulate him this year I
think he's finally broken out of that
guy status now this is one of my
favorites he has he has a name but for
the purposes we're calling a naked bow
staff fascist from Roma there means and
we infer meaning from Roma just the
degree of bravery and difficulty that
that that scene required to be spinning
a shower curtain rod so close to one's
own roughness and with such confidence
that it was seared into my retinas
that is a movie moment that will define
the year for me okay Hugh Grant
Paddington to came out here this year
the Baptist nominated him last year
well the Baptist can do whatever they
want Adam driver black Klansmen I never
bought that he was in the situation that
he was in I think it's a great
performance I stand by it but he will
have a movie that could be in this
category probably every year until he
gets hit by the number two downtown yeah
I'm gonna say this I think Danielle just
recontextualized how I approach awards
season permanently the older they are
you got to give them that word now we
have some people there's no possible way
and screw this up but no Roth is gonna
vote twice I'm gonna tattoo these rules
and the nominees are Hugh Grant from
Paddington - Daniel Kaluga from widow's
Michael B Jordan black panther Jesse
Plemons game night Jorge Antonio
Guerrero ake a naked both staff fascist
from Rome we have no nominations in
common with the Academy see their
Academy you got it
totally wrong our next category Best
Supporting Actress it's a lot like Best
Supporting Actor except it's women
instead of men looks like right now
racial vice has enough support to just
go straight through any objections Tessa
Thompson and Emma Stone both have three
total votes it's not a majority okay now
we have 90 people for to chicken again
because although I agree with you guys
that that was an impressive feat burnt
chicken too
it was just being itself versus acting
you said the chicken is just being
itself how many chickens do you know the
chickens commands my chicken are we
using movie magic to make it appear
concern that the mathematician is all
post-production
I think it's Andy Serkis and yell you
brought up you know how many
performances are we gonna have left from
this chicken what's the lifespan your
souls and say that when I had the chance
to vote for mathematic it let's give our
mathematicians their rose all right
they're alive dude I'm not taking them
out of the chicken off the list we're
going 12 rounds on this amoreena dude
tobira for roma all right Amy Adams for
Vice I'll vote to keep her there okay
and my you sasaki from shoplifters and
the only reason that I'm the only person
that's cuz I'm the only one that saw her
beautiful performance in this
heartwarming film
you gotta start wrenching I am
definitely you sold me I'm watching
shoplifters can we do a companion video
or a broth just scold us for the
nominees are Regina King if Beale Street
could talk Cynthia areevo bad times at
the El Royale Tessa Thompson sorry to
bother you Rachael vice the favorite
Emma Stone the favorite this time around
we have three in common with the Academy
so Academy way to step your game up this
next one's a biggie Mike and they're all
Biggie's we're only doing the biggies
this is the Best Actor category we've
got Mandy Nicolas Cage every era Kate of
Cage yeah all you have to do is look at
the scene in the bathroom where he's in
his underwear slugging vodka like no
other actor in America yeah and what
it's one of those movies that like
everyone's like oh it's so goddamn crazy
I'm like alright let's see I'm like Tom
Cruise Mission Impossible fall out I was
just realizing that Daniels hit by a bus
tomorrow works even more because he
would do that on camera
he'll fling himself Tom Cruise is
actually going to get hit by a bus Steve
Buscemi for the death of Stalin I could
vote for him but you know what we lost
an Emmy to Steve Buscemi so you know
well our net in show dogs
Bojack I haven't seen show dog horsemen
and this is the only way I see making up
for it I did see show dogs Joe and Ben
Foster and Leave No Trace I'll vote to
keep performing it's a great performance
but he's he's one level the whole time
so food we take him for granted
taken for granted we definitely take
is the actor of this Jade I can I really
maintain this he is the Marlon Brando of
this generation he just doesn't get the
right parts it is all internal it comes
out through the eyes it comes out so
subtly it's part of the brilliance of
his acting come on Jacob cedar green
from the kill tease so this is her I
know nobody's gonna vote for this so let
me just make this pitch really quickly
to watch the guilty that all takes place
in one place it's rust on this one man's
performance he is finding a woman he is
taking a call in a 911 basically
dispatched their version of it and he
finds a woman who was kidnapped it's all
in his rough vote for Ben Foster
or that guy Ben Foster okay and Brady
not coy John drove yeah I think it's
worth seeking about three it's all right
watch the rider sorry Robert Redford
it's a great movie and it's a really fun
Tim it is most charming and that is
another movie that feels like that is
his career in a nutshell
nice job David Washington and W dates to
great performances so we have Christian
Bale
we have been foster craft the nominees
for Best Actor are Christian Bale vise
Nicolas Cage Mandy Ben Foster Leave No
Trace Joaquin Phoenix
you were never really here look Keith
Stanfield sorry to bother this time
around we only had one in common with
the Oscars so I guess Oscars got four
wrong up next
the Best Actress category a few on the
board that seem to have majority support
Toni Collette ready Terry also Elsie
Fisher eighth grade yes
and then you Lucio from Roma also got a
majority so yeah okay Natalie Portman in
box luxe I will vote to keep her here
just me okay well it's a great
performance you should see it Natalie
Portman again annihilation not enough
three three no sorry Natalie maybe split
the vote I don't teach you Natalie
Portman to not be so good in multiple
movies every day Kathryn Hahn private
life I'm that's not it's a bummer the
movie it's it's a serious drama from her
but man she is spectacular yeah I have
not seen it but Kathryn Khan is one of
our greatest treasures storm read in a
wrinkle in time I does not say everyone
time making the short list I'm not gonna
lie lazy absurd movie the whole time I'm
going what the fact that she can take me
from what to actually feeling something
when she encounters her dad for the
first time she goes on the Joanna Kulig
Joanna cold war cold war which once
again everyone see cold war be a
fantastic film and you guys once again
are not gonna vote for Joanna who does
deserve to be on the board
don't you eraser god damn it see movie
lady gaga stars born Lady gaga
did a more than serviceable job the
performances in the movie like the vocal
performances are great but I knew she
could do that
pretty good but I mean I get this yeah
it's just something slightly unexpected
we don't like a man a chicken Viola
Davis and widows 5 Wow
so there you go to filter out there they
featured the same dog dog do man wait a
minute wait a minute is the Best Actor
Best Actor why is we know what it's a
dog but talk about splitting a moment
like is it for game Mangano's well I
mean it's clearly for game day if the
Liberty the dog and Natalie Portman
could both pick one good movie to be in
every year then they might both be
nominated
the nominees are Olivia Colman the
favorite yalitza aparicio for roma toni
collette
hereditary
Viola Davis widows LLC Fisher this one
has two in common with the Oscars
Academy whiffed on three what category
are we doing next
it's Best Director almost unanimously
boots rightly sorry to bother ya Ari
Esther hereditary yes just first movie
he did that first Joe Cohen ballot
buster Scruggs this is not crystal for
McQuarrie Mission Impossible fall out
enough respect but this one in
particular is all the directions those
long takes
panos cosmatos from Mandy he created
such a weird amazing ride yeah it's like
an original world
yeah okay yes all right all right you
shot it on plastic bags and so the film
looks crazy
Morgan Neville yes documentarian first
of all well you be my neighbor was
snubbed entirely by the Academy Awards
shamefully sold you're erasing it aren't
you sorry Rob but did he give us a fire
fest uh Chloe
Zoe I'll see the writer it's a
beautifully rendered film that she
brought to us with real stories of real
people it's very emotionally a bo
burnham eighth grade Alfonso Cuaron Romo
Spike Lee black clansmen Lin Ramsey you
were never really here
Lutz Riley sorry to bother
in this category we had two in common
with the Oscars for Best Director this
one is the biggie the big enchilada for
all the marbles the biggest trophy and
all of sports it's for Best Picture we
are only going for five the Academy does
seven to ten or whatever but why it's
because it's old school rock we're
traditionally so these are our picks
black pants are not not amongst our
picks Aquaman you Marvel shells there
are two is it seem that majority support
sorry to bother you and eighth grade
both seem to sail through as a The
Ballad of Buster Scruggs I'm more of a
bird boxman stars born listen they
proved they could really make a movie
[Laughter]
annihilation
it's a good movie but I don't know the
Bears if the bear scene was featureless
I heard the favorite I think is the
weirdest movie to ever win Best Picture
and I'm excited for it can I pull mine
back and switch it from what I'm gonna
give it to a variety so yeah gonna so
three yeah yeah and Roma for Great War
for Roma
all right you couldn't let Beale Street
not have well I mean I feel like
spider-verse yeah spider-verse and Roman
sorry happy about it Best Picture
[Laughter]
but I'm into it here are the nominees
[Music]
Roma eighth grade sorry to bother you
the favorite
spider-man into the spider-verse this
time around we had to in common so once
again the Academy it not new a good job
it came up well there you have it what
did you think of our nominations what
did you agree with what did we leave out
let us know in the comments we want to
know I want to thank you for watching
screen junkies and also Academy if
you're watching I know you might need a
host this guy hit me up at Hal Rudman
thanks again for watching bye bye